- YOU WILL BE
IN ROOM 237.
AND YOU HAVE
FREE WI-FI THERE.
ALSO, FROM 6:00 A.M.
TO 10:00 A.M. EVERY MORNING,
THERE'S A FREE
CONTINENTAL BREAKFAST.
- HMM.
- YES, FROM 6:00 A.M.
TO 10:00 A.M.
[phone rings]
- SO IT'S CONTINENTAL, THEN.
- MM-HMM, YEP.
[Muzak in background]
- VERY GOOD.
[gasps]
EH, GARCON.
[chuckles]
ONE ADMISSION
FOR THE CONTINENTAL BREAKFAST.
- YOU CAN JUST
HELP YOURSELF, SIR.
- HMM, INTERESTING.
EUROPEAN STYLE.
[light classical music]
[chuckling]
MM.
AHH.
WHEN IN ROME...
♪ ♪
HMM, THE FORBIDDEN FRUIT.
[chortles]
WELL, AREN'T YOU
A TINY PLUM.
♪ ♪
WELL, LA...DEE...
DA.
PAPER AND EVERYTHING.
AND WHO ARE YOU,
MY LITTLE FRIEND?
NOT A SPOON...
NOT A FORK...
BUT SOMETHING IN BETWEEN.
A "FPOON".
[chuckles]
WHAT WILL YOU THINK OF NEXT,
GERMANY?
[humming softly]
AHH.
[chuckles delightedly]
ALL THE "EURO-PINE" COUNTRIES
LAY BEFORE ME.
WHERE SHOULD I FLY TO FIRST?
AHH.
THE PIT OF THE DOUGHNUT.
MM, THANK YOU, TURKEY.
MM, BUCKLE UP.
LET'S SEE
WHERE WE SHALL GO NEXT.
AH, THE DANISH!
CLEARLY FROM BRUSSELS.
MM.
MM, MM!
MM!
HELLO, GREECE,
WHERE THE YOGURT FLOWS
LIKE WATER.
MM, YES,
LIKE GO-GURT,
BUT TO STAY.
[chuckles]
MM.
MM, SO GOOD!
MM, PULLING INTO SPAIN.
MM!
BAKED TO PERFECTION.
CAN YOU BELIEVE IT?
IT ALL COMES
WITH THE ROOM!
[laughing]
MM!
MM, MM!
YES!
MM!
I LOVE BEING INCONTINENT!
A DELIGHT TO THE SENSES,
ISN'T IT, MY FRIEND?
ISN'T IT? YES!
I'LL HAVE
WHAT I'M HAVING!
[music crescendos]
I'LL HAVE...
WHAT I'M HAVING!
[woman singing angelically]
[sobbing]
SO GOOD.
IT'S SO GOOD.
- THANKS.
OH, GOOD AFTERNOON, SIR.
HOW CAN I HELP YOU?
- WELL, DAVIS,
I WILL BE STAYING
INDEFINITELY.
- BUT, SIR, DON'T YOU KNOW
THAT YOU'VE ALWAYS BEEN HERE?
[romantic big band music]
♪ ♪
- REALLY?
- MM-HMM.
- CONTINENTAL BREAKFAST?
- RIGHT AROUND THE CORNER.
♪ ♪